numbers were never my strong suit pierce
brosnan will forever be known as
double-oh-seven my name is bond James
Bond but you might not know that he was
originally slated for the role nearly a
decade before he got to say those iconic
words it just wasn't meant to be I guess
what happened only eats he followed
Pierce's nine-year journey to becoming
Bond well there was good business a bad
business remains to be seen
[Music]
in 1986 after four seasons on Remington
Steele pierce brosnan was looking for
the next chapter of his career and word
around town was Pierce might become the
fourth actor to portray the world's most
famous secret agent I've been practicing
this lately is there a bond part in your
future no I no one's ever asked me but
that didn't slow down speculation over
the next few months with Remington
Steele on the verge of cancellation
there was nothing to stop Pierce from
becoming the next double-oh-seven me and
that's when a dilemma arose that could
only happen in Hollywood I think not
Pierce's media attention for being in
the running to play bond actually
boosted the ratings of Remington Steele
that summer this led to NBC ordering
more episodes for the series which
forced Pierce to honor his contract and
prevented him for becoming pond I mean
the pen was poised over the contract and
there you go it just didn't work out it
was one of those situations UT caught up
with Pierce soon after Timothy Dalton
was announced as the next James Bond my
reaction to my not getting it there's no
working out or to Timothy Dalton getting
it Timothy is a good friend of mine I
think he's going to be very good in it I
think it's an excellent choice
I was disappointed but I think I'm a
strong believer in fate and I think
certain things I meant to happen for a
reason in life and God it wasn't we
tried hard enough cubby broccoli and
United Artists and myself to make it
work and it just didn't work so it just
wasn't meant to be I guess there's only
six more shows of Remington Steele I'd
like to get those over and done with as
quickly as possible and move on I mean I
can understand this situation it was
business I guess they did what they had
to do whether it was good business or
bad business remains to be seen
Brosnan's fans also took issue with the
situation with many even gathering
outside of the network's headquarters
two months later Pierce told Ichi how it
felt on losing the role did you ever
think you'd be back doing Remington
still you know what no I mean I thought
I'd lost Remington Steele away in a
closet and thrown away the key as it
were because in regardless of bond I
mean I was quite happy I was quite
content that it had finished I think the
show had run its course as far as I was
concerned but obviously other people
didn't and one has a contract to honor
as it were so over the next few years
Pierce was still able to retain a James
Bond image in pop culture and he told ET
in 1991 what he had learned from being a
Hollywood actor I mean for me it's
always been a surprise how my career has
unfolded and I've never really kind of
the times I've tried to push it along
I've met resistance so the best thing is
just to yield to it and just you know be
happy in the moment of what you're doing
and don't fret about it because you get
older and you're good
the road with acting gets a little
tougher and also you see where you've
been you see some of the pitfalls when
you've fallen down and it's just
experience really doesn't mean that you
can you know you're gonna wake up you
know a week from now and be totally
destroyed and kind of what you have to
deal with it and you just really have to
let it go at times it's not that
important what we do cut to 1994 the
franchise was once again looking for an
actor to step into the iconic role after
Timothy Dalton's run and did you know
those movies that I've done a ver
they're there they're done I now become
part of a rather wonderful history which
hopefully will go on I'm going well and
successfully and Pierce's name just so
happened to be thrown back into the ring
including an endorsement from one former
Bond actor that we then discuss it
Sean is a friend as is Timothy Dalton
I suppose you know I've been asked you
know who do you see and I think what
Pierce Brosnan was was one choice for it
and would still be a very good choice I
also had like Sam Neill I think you know
the Australian which is almost British
in June of 1994 it finally happened
after losing out on the role almost a
decade earlier Pierce Brosnan was
announced as the next James Bond
Goldeneye premiered to rave reviews and
box office success the following year it
was like unfinished business
upon the movies debut Pierce revealed
zet something kind of surprising about
his first chance at Bond do you think it
was meant to be that way and it's
probably better I think so I think
there's a certain maturity to me as a
man now as an actor and if the truth be
known back in 86 quietly and secretly to
myself I was very relieved that I didn't
get it because I don't think they're
very big shoes to fill
I mean Sean Connery cast a long large
shadow not to take anything away from
Roger Moore who did a magnificent job
and it was only when I began to do the
job myself that I realized what an
amazing job Roger did because he did it
for seven years and he may
the pot his own for some crazy reason it
came round to me again and I think when
something happens in your life for a
second time it carries a certain
significance and I couldn't have said no
to it I had to say yes well I really am
surprised to hear you say there was an
element of relief in 86 no I look at
myself back then in 86 and I just think
God they offered me this job of bond and
I was gonna do it but there's a certain
wait there's a certain presence and
sudden things have happened in life and
when you get kind of I don't know kicked
around a bit and you know you've you've
been down on the floor as it were you
just it's a great learning process so
when the phone rang this time and when I
you know Timothy decided not to do it I
was I felt aware that it was gonna come
back into my life again because the
opinion poll started up your show was
running opinion polls who was gonna do
it and so when it finally did come my
way I thought well let's just do it you
know it was there was no fear or
trepidation I mean I got nervous yes but
I just I felt very comfortable doing the
role yep once again we see you time
heals all wounds it's time for that be
showing tears went on a star in four
memorable James Bond installments
I love bond and I love the hole in a
grass you said we all grew up with it
and it's very precious to me
so I'm trying to look after it when
Daniel Craig took over as
double-oh-seven
Pearce pass along this message quote he
just said go for it you'll have the ride
of your life
[Music]